president Trump fighting back against
critics during a fiery Rose Garden news
conference where he officially declared
a national emergency on the southern
border we're going to be signing today
and registering national emergency and
it's a great thing to do because we have
an invasion of drugs invasion of gangs
invasion of people and it's unacceptable
I could do the wall over a longer period
of time I didn't need to do this but I'd
rather do it much faster and I don't
have to do it for the election I've
already done a lot of wall for the
election 2020 and the only reason we're
up here talking about this is because of
the election Chuck Schumer and Nancy
Pelosi blasting the decision as a quote
power grab they're also signaling that
Democrats are ready to fight it out in
the courts president Trump's
sarcastically responding to any
potential legal challenges we will have
a national emergency and we will then be
sued and they will sue us in the ninth
circuit even though it shouldn't be
there and we will possibly get a bad
ruling and then we'll get another bed
ruling and then we'll end up in the
Supreme Court and hopefully we'll get a
fair shake and we'll win in the Supreme
Court the bill becomes a law and how the
bill goes to court yes and he said it in
such kind of a nice sing-songy way that
even a child like and then this happens
okay so the thing that we have to remind
everybody when you're when you're
listening to smug reporters that when
the caravans were here it was a national
emergency at that time America was being
compared to Nazi Germany because we were
separating remember was separating
families and putting children in cages
it was a horrifying Amanah terian crisis
so you finally get the president to
agree that this is an unacceptable
situation and we should apply some
solutions and some of the Democrats are
mocking it
oh it's know of no longer an emergency
even though we said that it was like
Nazi Germany just months ago so for the
median for the Democrats the caravan
caravan is a national emergency
till it's no longer visual so which are
left with our adults trying to solve the
underlying issue that led to this crisis
which is I mean think about this whether
it is terror or mass shootings you don't
just assume everything is fine when the
attack is over you go back you figure
out how do you prevent that that's all
that's going on right now and to laugh
at this and say it's not a humanitarian
crisis you were the same people
screaming bloody murder that it was that
it was we have some sound from one of
the exchanges with a reporter you're
gonna want to talk about this Pete take
a listen what do you say to your critics
who say that you are creating a national
emergency that you're concocting a
national emergency here in order to get
your wall angels what do you think you
think I'm creating something ask these
incredible women who lost their
daughters and their sons okay
because your question is a very
political question because you have an
agenda no no wait sit down sit down
could you please sit down you get one
question I would say you talked about
visuals great yeah the angel moms were
the most powerful part of this press
conference he used them in his in
opening remarks and then when Jim Acosta
tried to come at him and use the stats
to talk about the stats he said there
you are the left does the emotional
visual so well so often and we rarely
see that from conservatives or
Republicans because they give me fun we
talk stats but that visual right there
these are people affected by this and
the comparison is remember on the left
and the medium went wall to wall on the
very unfortunate circumstance were the
two kids who were handed over to ice in
custody as their parents brought them on
the perilous journey passed away after
everything we do for them
that was wall to wall coverage there's
almost no coverage
other than this channel on these angel
moms and these circumstances when
illegals go wrong that's the point the
president is making I think a lot of
people watching this feel that
viscerally mm-hmm and did Acosta asked
President Obama Nancy Pelosi and all the
Democrats did he did he stop them and
say you know is this a manufactured
humanitarian
when they were all out there calling
yeah there were clips of Obama and
Pelosi and all these Democrats calling
it and acknowledging that this was a
humanitarian crisis no reporters
question them on if they all said oh
yeah they want to address that they want
to do something about it he had no
choice but to do this national emergency
this was not matter she didn't have a
choice I mean he could have taken the
original deal which was terrible he
could have taken this this new bill
that's an atrocity as I said yesterday
but the bottom line is as I said
yesterday also it's either national
emergency or it's not and he was in a
position now where he felt like there's
no no movement for me here I'm not
getting any help from Democrats they're
not interested at this point in calling
this what it is which is a national
emergency because to do that would give
me a victory in 2020 or would give some
credence to what I've been saying so
unless I actually declare this and
figure out a way to move some of this
money around I'm not gonna get the money
for the wall they're not interested in
the barriers and they put so many
obstacles forth in this spending bill
that you know you can't have this type
of wall you can't have a wall of that
type in this place enabling towns and
counties disrupt the butterfly you can't
do anything I mean I mentioned one that
in my ear they tell me that just FYI the
House Judiciary Committee has announced
that they are and launching an immediate
investigation into this executive action
they've sent letters to the President to
that effect let's get your thoughts you
haven't spoken yet well I think the key
thing for me is that the Justice
Department told me was a high litigation
risk with this strategy I don't think
there's an emergency of any kind to say
there's a humanitarian crisis well I
guess there was a humanitarian crisis in
December I guess it was a humanitarian
crisis two years ago so you don't want
to fix it let me finish and so you have
a situation where he didn't declare an
emergency there now today and I think
this was telling he says you know what I
don't need to do this but I'd rather do
it faster boy if I was a lawyer I'd say
your honor the president said he doesn't
need to do this there's no invasion
there's nobody attacking America this is
not a milk when another child dies you
will change the line this is a situation
where I think it was Ann Coulter a real
conservative who said the only national
emergency is the president is an idiot
now you agree with Ann Coulter
damn but to me you look at the idea of
the national emergency and what I see is
that you guys are saying well maybe
because you want to support the prison I
can appreciate that but I gotta tell you
something the Wall Street Journal
editorial page National Review I could
even go on the number of Republicans in
the Senate including Mitch McConnell
Senate Majority who tried to get the
Prince to say don't do this because
there's one day going to be president
Alexandria or Cascio Cortez but you know
what I just what's great now is I want
to I want to hear the Dems tell me that
fentanyl is no longer a problem
human trafficking is no longer a problem
gang violence is no longer a problem
sexual abuse is no longer a problem the
Dems are walking into a huge trap it's
already happening you saw it with Vader
all down yeah all you have to do then we
play that yes this mm-hmm
if you could would you take the wall
down now here yes like you have a wall
absolutely knock it down I'll take the
wall do you think the city you think of
this if there's a referendum here in
this city that I do it's cost us tens of
billions of dollars to build and to
maintain and it has pushed migrants and
asylum seekers and refugees to the most
inhospitable the most hostile stretches
of the us-mexico border ensuring their
suffering and death well okay this is we
talked about this a couple of weeks ago
that if they believe something is
immoral shouldn't you remove the
existing immorality and that is the
existing walls so it's a trap that
they've walked into and now he says yes
and you know l said yes kirsten
gillibrand
is it Gillibrand Gillibrand whatever
anyway the point is now Gillibrand thank
you so the fact is each one is now going
to be faced with this question wherever
they go and you're gonna have to have
two choices
remove the immorality or side with Trump
it's not a case of Kirsten it's not a
case of how of whether in the national
emergency is now or two months ago the
president has said it's an emergency for
that long Congress can't figure it out
they can't address it they haven't been
able to deal with the emergency as a
result as the executive who's charged
with our security he says I have to take
it in and what secure it's not a
security issue
the Blitz when the president says oh
this is about drugs most drugs come
through legal ports of entry when oh
when the president says it's about
illegal immigration guess what illegal
immigration is down substantially like
radically since 2000 because when he
sells Oh Mike no it's not because no
problems here talk about walls this is
there other wasters say you know to me
it's like you don't want to hear it so